CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE, TRAIT
ADVISOR PETER NAVARRO, HUD
SECRETARY DOCTOR BEN CARSON.
ALSO STANDING BY DOCTOR STEVE
CORWIN WHO WON SOME OF THE
BIGGEST HOSPITALS IN THE NEW
YORK POLITY AND AREA.
ONE OF THE HARDEST HIT BY THE
PANDEMIC.
ALSO AHEAD, CUSTOMS AND BORDER
COMMISSIONER MARK MORGAN,
CONGRESSMAN DOUG COLLINS AND
DR. MARC SIEGEL.
AN IMPORTANT HOUR AHEAD
INDEED.
BUT FIRST, MY OPEN.
WHAT A DIFFERENCE A WEEK
MAKES.
YEP, IT’S REAL, AND IS ALREADY
CHANGING OUR LIVES.
AND GUESS WHAT, THAT CHANGE IS
GOING TO CONTINUE.
WE DO NOT KNOW WHEN IT WILL
ENDS, BUT WHAT WE DO KNOW IS
WE ARE FACING A SEEMINGLY
INCOMPARABLE ENEMY VIRUS
INFLICTING SICKNESS AND IN
SOME CASES DEATH AS IT WASHES
ACROSS THE WORLD.
I SIT HERE TONIGHT IN NEW YORK
CITY, IN NEW YORK STATE, WHICH
IS OF THIS MOMENT RAPIDLY
CLOSING IN ON 12000 CONFIRMED
CASES OF THE CORONAVIRUS.
BY FAR, THE MOST OF ANY STATE
IN THE NATION.
BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE, THIS
VIRUS IS EVERYWHERE.
AND ALL OF US NEED TO BE
VIGILANT, AND MOST OF US NEED
TO STAY IN PLACE.
THE NUMBERS WE HAVE SEEN FROM
CHINA, SOUTH KOREA, ITALY, THE
UNITED STATES SUGGESTED
DIFFERENT MORTALITY RATES.
CHINA, IT APPEARS IS BACK
ONLINE.
SOUTH KOREA SEEMS LIKE IT IS
AT THE END AS WELL.
AND ITALY, AS YOU PROBABLY
KNOW IS BEING DEVASTATED WITH
800 DEATHS REPORTED IN THE
LAST 24 HOURS.
SO HOW WILL THE UNITED STATES
GET THROUGH THIS?
WHO WILL BE LEAD ON ALONG THE
WAY?
I DON’T HAVE ALL OF THE
ANSWERS, BUT THERE ARE FOUR
THINGS I KNOW FOR SURE.
NUMBER ONE, WE WILL GET
THROUGH THIS.
REMEMBER, WE ARE AMERICANS,
BOARD OF A REVOLUTION, VICE IS
IN OUR DNA.
AMERICAS AT OUR BEST WHEN SHE
IS TESTED.
SHE IS STRONG, DETERMINED, AND
HAS THE METAL TO GET THROUGH
ANYTHING.
THE WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE IS MAKING SURE WE
WILL GET THROUGH THIS WITH THE
BEST OF THE BEST ENGAGED ON
OUR BEHALF.
A WHOLE OF GOVERNMENT
RESPONSES ON THIS.
SINCE PRESIDENT TRUMP
IMPLEMENTED TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS ON CHINA, AND
THEN EUROPE, THEN CLOSED
NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN ORDERS
TO NONESSENTIAL TRAVEL, WE ARE
PROTECTING OUR CITIZENS AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
THE FDA HAS ISSUED AN
EMERGENCY APPROVAL FOR TESTING
AND HAS CUT ITS REDTAPE.
AMERICANS ARE BEING TESTED FOR
FREE.
THE FAST TRACK RIGHT NOW IS
THE ONLY TRACK IN AMERICA.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BROUGHT
TOGETHER BANK EXECUTIVES,
INSURERS, PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES, AIRLINES AND
STORES.
NUMBER TWO, WHEN WE GET
THROUGH THIS WE WILL BE
STRONGER THAN EVER.
ECONOMISTS AGREE THAT ONCE
THIS VIRUS PLATEAUS, AS IT
HASN’T OTHER COUNTRIES, OUR
ECONOMY WILL COME ROARING
BACK.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SIGNED AN
EMERGENCY CORONAVIRUS PACKAGE
INJECTING $8.3 BILLION INTO
THE EFFORTS TO FIGHT THIS
OUTBREAK.
TAX DAY IS DELAYED UNTIL JULY,
STUDENT LOAN PAYMENTS ARE
SUSPENDED FOR 60 DAYS, THERE
IS A MORATORIUM ON FHA
FORECLOSURES.
AND THIS WEEK STIMULUS PACKAGE
WILL PROVIDE AT LEAST $1200.
ADULT WHO MAKES $75000 A YEAR
OR LESS.
ALL IN AN EFFORT TO GET TO THE
POINT WHERE WE CAN BE STRONGER
WHEN WE GET OUT OF THIS.
THIS IS THE KIND OF HOLES
GOVERNMENT RESPONSE AMERICAN
HAVE NEVER SEEN BEFORE, THIS
IS THE RESPONSIBLE PRIDE IS A
GEM PROVIDE US WITH THE
ABILITY TO COME BACK.
NUMBER THREE, WE ARE FINDING
COMMON GROUND IN UNUSUAL
PLACES.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BROUGHT
TOGETHER FORMER COMPETITORS TO
FIGHT THIS TOGETHER, ALL
FOCUSED ON AMERICA’S COMMON
ENEMY.
COMPANIES AND WORKERS ARE
VOLUNTEERING EVEN THOUGH THEY
ARE SUFFERING FINANCIALLY.
THEY ARE STEPPING UP WITH
MASKS AND DRIVE-THROUGH’S FOR
TESTING.
AND AMAZINGLY, EVEN POLITICS
COMPREHENDS THE NEED FOR
COMMON GROUND.
>> WITH RESPECT TO GOVERNOR
CUOMO WE HAD A GREAT TALK THIS
MORNING.
WE’RE BOTH DOING A VERY GOOD
JOB.
HE’S DOING A PHENOMENAL JOB ON
THIS.
EVEN GAVIN NEWSOM.
WE ARGUE A LOT BUT GAVIN
NEWSOM HAS BEEN VERY
GENEROUS.
>> I SPOKE TO THE PRESIDENT
THIS MORNING ABOUT SPECIFIC
ACTIONS THE PRESIDENT IS GOING
TO TAKE.
I CAN TELL YOU HE IS FULLY
ENGAGED ON TRYING TO HELP NEW
YORK HE’S BEING VERY CREATIVE
AND VERY ENERGETIC.
AND I THANK HIM FOR HIS
PARTNERSHIP.
JUDGE JEANINE: NUMBER FOUR, WE
ARE GETTING CLOSE TO OUR
HUMANITY, OUR FAITH, AND OUR
PURPOSE IN LIFE.
THE SILENCE OF ISOLATION IS
DEAFENING.
IT IS FORCING US TO THINK
ABOUT OUR PURPOSE.
WE ARE SOCIAL BEINGS BUT MAYBE
THE SILVERLINING WILL BE THAT
TIME WE HAVE TWO SELF EXAMINE,
REFLECT, AND GET CLOSER TO OUR
CREATOR.
VICE PRESIDENT PENTZ SAID
TODAY THE RELIGIOUS
COMMUNITIES HAVE HAD TO MAKE
THE HARD CHOICE TO SUSPEND
SERVICES.
SO MAYBE YOU CAN PRACTICE YOUR
FAITH BY FINDING THAT SENIOR
CITIZEN IN YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD
WHO CAN’T GET TO THE STORE,
WHO CAN’T COOK HIS OR HER OWN
MEALS, DO SOMETHING FOR THEM.
OUR KIDS, THE ONES WHO ARE
DANCING ON THE BEACH LAST
WEEKEND IN FLORIDA, HAVE A LOT
OF ENERGY.
GET THEM OUT OF THE HOUSE TO
HELP OTHERS.
BE SINCERE.
BE KIND, AND BE TEMPERATE.
MAKE A VALID TO GIVE.
REMEMBER THE IMPORTANCE OF
LOVE.
AND FAMILY.
THE DARKNESS OF THE PRESENCE,
WILL ONLY FADE AS THE
BRIGHTNESS OF THE FUTURE IS
JUST TO BE ON THE HORIZON.
I LOOK FORWARD TO ENJOYING
THAT DAY WITH YOU.